en este centro de detención en el
sudeste de lituania llegan migrantes
indocumentados después de cruzar la
frontera con belarús más de cuatro mil
han entrado a lituania ilegalmente
durante este año la mayoría proveniente
de irak un número de emigrantes sin
precedentes para este país báltico que
cuenta con 2.8 millones de habitantes el
año pasado el total fue de 74
ante la cantidad de migrantes el
parlamento lituano aceleró la
construcción de una valla de 500
kilómetros a lo largo de la frontera al
sur del país un proyecto de 152 millones
de euros
será una gran valla
cuatro metros de alto con alambre de
púas adherido
será una barrera física bastante sólida
adicionalmente las tropas lituanas están
autorizadas a patrullar la frontera y
regresar a las personas que no tienen
autorizada la entrada al territorio
vilna acusa a minsk de crear una crisis
inmigratoria intencionalmente llevando
migrantes desde el aeropuerto
internacional de su capital a la
frontera con lituania esto con fin de
ejercer presión sobre la unión europea
en medio de una creciente ola de
sanciones contra el autoritario gobierno
de alexandr lukashenko sus tres yemas
verdad no propuso a más este régimen es
impredecible y una barrera física es la
medida que puede ayudar seriamente a
tratar cualquier tipo de amenaza que
venga del lado de los rusos rusos luego
de unas elecciones ampliamente
cuestionadas en 2020 que terminaron con
sexto mandato consecutivo para el
presidente su gobierno se inauguró con
una violenta respuesta a las protestas a
la oposición política y disidencia
pública ni la unión europea ni lituania
reconocen a lukashenko como el líder
legítimo del país la próxima semana los
ministros unión europea mantendrán
conversaciones sobre la crisis
migratoria